[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bienvenue oh yeah
[Rires]
la dernière fois ça avait quand même
bien fonctionné ça on est retour avec
été positifs
des questions incroyables comme toujours
le public sans filtre
les meilleurs
j'ai commencé que la question
j'ai mis la question la plus corsée
des questions même pas vu
ça se peut qu'il y a des questions qu'on
surtout pas à la première question
surtout pas la première question puis
c'est notre opinion puis notre opinion
on peut pas être faux parce que parce
que c'est le nom explique-moi OK
[Rires]
spéculoos Queen
j'ai mis les noms cette fois-ci OK
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de la saison 2
de cette année grosse question on a
débattu en nous si on en parlait si on
faisait un podcast sur le sujet on
pensait aux invités potentiels on
pensait à qui avec qui on pourrait
parler de ça ou si on a fait les deux de
ça parce que ça a été gros là on est
quand même
dans deux semaines depuis la finale et
pas c'est pas facile
c'est pas fini mais pendant que ça va
sortir ça va être fini enfin que de
toute façon dans la tête de plusieurs
c'est des jeunes déjà terminé puis puis
une des raisons pourquoi on voulait pas
nécessairement où on a on a décidé de
finalement pas en parler c'est parce que
ni toi ni moi avons écouté l'émission ça
existe les murs on va parler de ça
qu'on est colonie marche aussi
j'aimerais y aller avec la préface que
je suis quand même c'est quoi
genre j'ai peut-être un guest un petit
peu plus éduqué sur l'arrière de
qu'est-ce qui aurait pu se passer que
certains commentateurs qu'on a vu passer
sur Twitter dans les dans les derniers
mois là mais oui on l'oublie on oublie
que tu as fait tremble
en plein milieu de la nuit en criant
la chanson que je tombe dans un shop
post traumatique mais non c'est ça
qu'est-ce qu'on en a pensé
cette saga là je peux me lancer oui ben
tu peux lancer et moi je voulais juste
dire faire une préface de pourquoi
pourquoi je l'ai pas écouté cette année
parce que moi
sans fil savent que j'ai quand même fan
de pitié de à part cette année à chaque
année je l'ai écouté religieusement
c'était malgré mettons le côté
superficiel de tout ça puis le côté
genre becherie puis le côté nanana que
c'était quand même
GG réellement passé que c'était comme
positif dans société ou des parce que
mettons au travers des émissions qui est
comme finalement
de revendications
moi je me disais vu que ça parle à tout
le monde il y a vraiment beaucoup de
monde même si nous autres mettons ces
gens de réflexion là mettons peut-être
que nous autres on les a déjà eu mais
mettons
tout le monde des plus jeunes nous
demandons qui s'intéresse moins à ça que
je me dis bon mais ça peut quand même au
travail de ça une coupe de trucs qui
font comme avancer la réflexion sur les
sujets et tant mieux puis toute la
discussion parce que tu sais
la discussion autour
même car il y a quand même une
discussion qui a lieu qui fait que on
réfléchit collectivement à des trucs
mais pourquoi tu l'as pas écouté c'était
ça la préface
c'est plus négatif que c'est possible
dans le fond ouais on dirait que cette
saison aussi
je sais pas on dirait que peut-être que
moi ma réflexion avant c'est par rapport
à ça mais que
l'espèce de culture justement du
voyeurisme et puis du genre de
je trouve pas le meilleur mot que
bitchage
de fixe ça fait ce réseau social on
prend candidats sur douleur à quel point
qui se taper dessus puis tu sais puis on
dirait que
j'ai pas écouté j'ai écouté un peu grâce
un peu graisse un peu chez nous parce
que vous l'écoutez quand on habite
ensemble vous voulez écouter le dimanche
puis je venais l'écouter des fois et
vous autres puis cette date mais j'ai eu
l'impression qu'à chaque année
autant culturellement depuis les cinq
dernières années mettant on fait tout le
temps un pote plus vers
je veux dire à gauche mais je pense pas
que c'est exactement ce que l'éveil vers
l'éveil social mettons la planche au
même pour le mieux ou pour le pire
donc à chaque année on se dirige plus
vers là puis l'émission elle pas
vraiment même si ils font certains
efforts pour avoir des candidats trans
par exemple ou ce genre de choses là
mais l'essence même de od c'est
capitaliste à mort là puis c'est les
écoutes puis c'est les pubs puis c'est
tout ça tu sais avec l'émission
essentiellement change pas son modèle
d'affaires a jamais changé c'est-à-dire
du drama pour faire des vues puis ce que
j'ai eu l'impression on fait des années
c'est qu'à chaque édition
il y avait encore un scandale qui
gonflait encore plus là qui devenait
encore plus gros plus qui devenait
encore plus gros permet c'est quand même
c'est un émission là qu'est-ce qui est
en train de se passer genre là Kevin mon
étant des pétitions pour faire genre on
le sort de là qui avait une retourné à
tellement genre il y a un mais son
expérience
puis à chaque année c'est une nouvelle
affaire tellement plus grosse que là je
pense que c'est juste normal ça peut
plus que là ça fait plus gonfler ça peut
plus gonfler ouais puis là ce qui nous
amène à cette édition qui a juste
explosé ici on dirait ce qu'on voudrait
tu as parlé de drama mais genre là la
raison pour que le monde écoute ça
pourquoi ça aussi un succès
c'est une émission qui tourne autour du
drama puis que le monde aime le drame
la question se pose comme
on a besoin de la société
[Musique]
en plus de toute le drama qu'on a réel
du vrai drama pire que ça tu sais qui
occupe nos filles qui occupent nos
journaux qui occupent nos vies du drama
ben pire que ça
racheter ça quand c'est du
divertissement c'est ça c'est une
question à se poser mais
ceci étant dit pour en revenir à
l'émission comme tel j'ai réfléchi
beaucoup tu sais puis moi je trouve
qu'il y a personne qui a bien géré ça de
A à Z il y a personne qui vient gérer ça
parce que tu l'as dit maintenant qu'on
fait la chaîne des choses là tu le dis
le monde est que ça pour le drame fait
que des eaux du
drame tu vois du drama
c'est comme ce pourquoi tu écoutes ce
pourquoi tu écoutais mon année puis tu
aimais tellement ça que Joanis fasse
dépendre comme la [ __ ] Picasso intimidé
par mois à l'écran
il s'est passé pour vrai puis ça je
pense j'en ai déjà parlé par le passé et
puis j'en reparlerai pas maintenant mais
tu écoutes ça pour voir Joanie se faire
intimider par tout le monde à chaque
année c'est la main il y a rien de
nouveau sous le soleil l'après il y a eu
au lit après il y a eu Kevin
exactement la Providence chaque émission
était ça puis le modèle c'est ça fait
que le public de s'indigner quand il
revoit ça encore qui est la raison pour
laquelle ils l'ont écouté toutes les
années
réaction vraiment
offre du public la part du public la
part du public
probablement que c'est pas
nécessairement toute la même monde ou
bien que ça a juste comme c'est tout le
temps ça comme dépasser une ligne puis
encore une fois je veux dire on l'a pas
écouté est-ce que c'était pire cette
année peut-être c'est ce que le monde
semble dire mais c'était pas comme si
c'était chill non plus
l'émission la prod
pousser ça là
des gens
voulait que ce soit
en voulait à odé de revenir encore de la
même formule ça fait plusieurs années
déjà qu'une espèce de un espèce dont on
est tanné de ce qu'on se fait proposer
fait que l'espèce de d'ébullition du
public était juste au niveau pour que ça
ce soit trop alors que ça aurait été
développe deux ans et puis moi je pense
à être passé complètement sur le radar
faites premier acteur de l'équation qui
a qui agit drôlement le public le public
qui est un peu hypocrite parce que le
public adore le drama exact mais le
public a créé
deuxième acteur de l'équation qui agit
un peu oui la plancha un peu bizarre un
peu drôle un peu Fanny c'est les
commanditeurs parce que tu commandes ce
show-là depuis longtemps la raison pour
laquelle ce show-là a autant d'écoute
c'est précisément sur le drame puis ce
qui nous amène aussi peut-être à une
réflexion plus large on n'aura pas
aujourd'hui sur la console culture
qui est toujours les commandes d'heures
sont ceux qui décident qui se fait
consoler ou qui non au final c'est ça
les partenaires les commandes puis
eux ont décidé que ah ben là si le
public décide que là ils sont à chaud
ben soyons en guillemets hypocrites nous
aussi puis disons ah non nous on
s'associe pas chaud là mais pourtant
j'ai pas ma sœur que produit dans leur
bureau et encore laisse-moi des contrats
qui disent que vous vous associez à
chaud là mais oui c'est pour tout ce que
c'est pour le meilleur et pour le prix
mais au D c'est ça c'est ça c'est pas
comme si c'était pas ça tout le temps
toujours été ça depuis le début nous
gourou le guru même y était
du gourou même au déballés ils ont été
là à travers
les mots en N utilisé à télé nationale
sans jamais dire oh non là c'est trop
pour une autre mais là le public de
cette que c'est trop pour eux fait que
les commanditaires de cette que c'est
trop petit
ça devient aussi un spin marketing de se
retirer c'est ça moi je pense que le
premier qui le fait ça crée un effet
domino mais le premier qui le fait que
dit ah peut-être que si on fait un genre
de stateman qu'on sépare ça va tellement
faire jaser que ça va nous faire un coup
de pub incroyable faisons ça fait clac
il y en a un qui le fait plus les autres
ils disent aussi on va marquer dans le
train avec le boum boum boum il fait 2
minutes tout le monde le fait tu sais
mais c'est sûr c'est comme ok pourquoi
pourquoi là pourquoi de cette façon-là
c'est il y a un stunt médiatique c'est
fou deuxième facteur qui a réagi oui
bien évidemment le troisième acteur qui
aurait j'ai wild c'est la production là
ça a pas de sens c'est ils font un show
télé
ils peuvent pas
ce qui est le contenu de l'émission
c'est leur émission c'est leur émission
c'est les autres qui a créé de A à Z ces
autres qui font le concept qui
choisissent les candidats qui créent les
situations qui décide qu'est-ce qui
mettent au montage tout ce qu'on voit
c'est pour donner c'est pas juste comme
son papa
[Musique]
tout ce qu'on a vu était décidé qu'on le
voit tout ce qui a été mis à la télé a
été pour pour que le public le constat
ça aurait pu avec les rôles avec le
fauteuil d'Occupation Double des cinq
dernières années mettons le même je vais
prendre l'exemple de Bali parce que
j'étais dedans il y aurait pu faire 7
choses différents
trois semaines d'avance fait quand le
public commence à gronder tranquillement
que il y a trop d'intimidation ils ont
trois semaines pour s'ajuster ils font
pas on continue de mettre tes images là
et on continue au montage à chaque fois
qu'il y a eu des affaires de même que le
genre de controverse au dés c'est pas
justement c'est kevinceau de vidange
Charles qui était
chaque fois qu'il y a un genre de
Momentum de gens tout le monde parle
d'un truc
on le voit il pose il accélère
c'est la philosophie par les arbres et
parlez-en plus le monde en parle même si
il y a du monde s'ils sont pas d'accord
qui réagissent je le fait que ça fait
réagir à mettre la lumière sur
l'émission peut encore plus de monde
qu'il écoute exactement je vais prendre
l'exemple encore de Joannie puis moi
notre année qui est l'année de
rétrospective maintenant je peux je peux
size pourquoi il en fait ça parce que
justement
à peu près trois semaines avant qu'on
fasse un genre de
c'était comme un Secondaire en spectacle
qui appelait ça moi j'étais avec j'étais
avec Jesse plus Noémie puis on faisait
un sketch où est-ce qu'on riait de
toutes les candidats un après l'autre
puis là finalement la télé ce qu'on a vu
c'est juste nous quiions Joanie date
tout le monde ouais enfin on finit ça
rien de nous-même puis c'était quand
même un genre de sketch comme ça tu sais
puis mais à Télé ce qu'on a vu c'est
nous quiions
puis j'ai vu que trois semaines à peu
près avant ça ça commençait à être genre
le monde sur Internet c'était quand même
péage puis genre je prends pour un autre
là avec Joannie puis là genre il
s'étoffe le type là cette trame
narrative là est devenue tellement
grosse que lui en fait mais là on va pas
mettre le sketch au complet maintenant
on va juste mettre ça on s'est rendu ça
qui était trois semaines d'avance pour
le planifier fait qu'il planifie ces
affaires-là fait quand le public se met
en Shirley sur l'intimidation il y a
juste peser sur l'accélérateur
jusqu'à ce que les commanditaires là
surprise quand les commentaires là on
est pu en bac +
moi c'est ça la plus grande absurdité
puis gros problème de
double disco en fait l'espèce de
dissociation complète de toute
responsabilité par rapport à cette
affaire-là c'est votre émission c'est
c'est ces autres qui ont créé ça c'est
de tout mettre le blanc sur la
sur les candidats moi je trouve ça
débile les candidats je veux dire ils
ont peut-être ils ont sûrement des eu
des agissements et une
moralités
mais c'est quand même je t'ai choisi par
la prod
finalement la seule émission pour
arriver toute la fameuse émission
sauvetage c'est la seule émission que
j'ai écouté
puis parce que je t'ai trop curieux
parce que je savais comme comment qu'ils
vont rattraper ça qu'est-ce qu'ils vont
faire
qu'au final puis moi écouter cette
émission là
[Musique]
ridicule c'est un arrêt ridicule ça non
en tant que public
peut-être qu'elle fait de l'avoir pas
écouté aussi amène un certain recul mais
genre juste voir ça j'étais comme
j'avais l'impression de faire prendre
pour un purimbécile en écoutant cette
émission là
encore une fois ce que tu disais par
rapport au manque complet de prise de
conscience puis de prise de
responsabilité de la part de la prod
dans cette histoire-là quand ils disent
dans cette émission là justement il dit
on a fait plusieurs fois des
interventions les montres mettons la
nounou qui va voir les gars qui fait les
gars là une fois le 12 septembre
calmez-vous un peu juste pour les gens
qui nous écoutent qui savent peut-être
pas comment ça se passe des
interventions comme ça des nounous on en
a trois fois par jour pour un million
d'affaires fait que ces gens notre année
c'était comme Gee qui venait de voir
c'est comme là elle peut genre rabbaye
tout parce que quand tu es à poil on
peut pas aujourd'hui genre on peut pas
mettre ça sur caméra le soleil les gars
arrêtez de sacré on peut pas mettre ça
sur caméra tu sais tout le temps genre
des interventions même tout le temps les
gars arrêtez je suis allé tout le temps
toujours ça tout le temps à toutes les
jours et bien ils ont pris deux
calmez-vous un peu ce langage parce que
il voyait qu'au Québec ça commençait à
brasser un peu dans
le monde pour des caves carrément c'est
ça puis justement plus il arrive avec la
belle formation sur sur la violence puis
si ça puis là avec une adore le dire et
puis c'est quand même ce qu'elle a fait
c'est juste que le comment ça a été mis
en scène c'était comme bah on va
apprendre à nos petits pots c'est quoi
l'intimidation c'est quoi puis là
j'étais comme
c'est comme pour moi la chose la plus je
sais pas je comprends que peut-être
qu'il y en avait besoin mais tu sais
c'est comme
genre
une conversation collective sur
l'intimidation c'est pas vraiment ça que
c'est mais surtout juste le fait de
Gandou on fait notre part de thé on a
fait notre boutique chemin je veux dire
on parle d'intimidation si ça mais
c'était comme c'est trop peu trop tard
pour connaître du monde de priorité de
prix au loin de l'émission apparemment
que les dos de quelqu'un qui sont fait
dire vous êtes sortis genre
ça pour eux ça sentait complètement
nulle part
c'est comme ils se font dire ok ben vous
êtes en dehors l'émission vos parents
sont dans l'avion ils sont viennent de
vous rejoindre puis il vous ramène quoi
c'est comme
conscience de vouloir calmer le jeu les
gars il y a ça serait peut-être parlé
déjà mais oui c'est ça c'est pour ça
qu'on a pas vu la réaction des gars à
cette émission là je demande vous
montrer vous allez annoncé à tout le
monde les gars s'en vont mais ils ont
pas montré les gars qui sont comme what
the fuck c'est ça
éclaté mais c'était comme c'était bande
avec la tête un jour ou l'autre ça
l'arrivée
tout le temps d'aller plus loin dans le
drama plus loin dans comme faire agir le
monde ça se peut que ça finisse à faire
ça se peut que ça soit pas dingue qu'il
y a peut-être un genre de truc
puis la même soirée il y avait juste mon
en parle puis moi j'ai le même sentiment
j'étais comme
c'est elle vient comme faire son son
speech pilleurs son opération comme
image
restaurée au début plus possible et puis
pendant 4 jours à cause d'une affaire de
comment dites que lui qui pouvait pas
aller chercher la bouffe ailleurs puis
nanana mais là c'est tout le temps on
aura pas la bouffe aujourd'hui le
pendant 4 jours à m'amener c'est juste
des des graines de pain puis l'été puis
Christian
puis elle arrive devant la parole
avec ses affaires de il manquait barre
de peanut le matin le télécommande comme
si il se plaignait genre tout cuit dans
le bec lavande c'est comme c'est pour ça
que dit le genre c'est complètement
comme c'est technique de l'Épouvanteur
ça intéresse personne mais
notre année si on était à Bali
magnifique genre 35 dans le jour il y a
une journée complète le matin Sandrine
je pense réveil il faisait le café
toutes les matins il vient pour prendre
c'est des 18 dos qui était dans une
pente il y a plus d'eau dans pompe
d'habitude il y a plus d'eau dans la
pente qui crée un peu caméra de l'eau
il y a plus d'autres les gosses lèvent
il y a plus de café il y a pas d'eau
enfin il y a pas d'eau il y a pas d'eau
genre là
la chose la plus fondamentale
finalement c'est juste qu'en pelote on a
tellement tôt on va passer la journée au
complet pudo à 40 degrés à 40 degrés
jusqu'à temps qui arrive le soir plus
Guy arrive notre nounou y arrive avec
genre
excusez les gars c'est quand même quoi
excuser les gars genre qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé
dans la maison des filles
ça brossait la maison des filles fait
qu'il y a pas un institut
de brasser un tabarnak
était focus il y a plus d'eau
un peu taf ça non plus
c'est que tout le monde que je connais
qui l'écoutait Audi après cet événement
là arrêtez d'écouter je pense que je
serais curieux de voir les codes
d'écoute
on entend même plus parler nulle part et
que tout le monde qui l'écoute plus
pourquoi
parce que moi
le monde qui l'ont écouté m'ont dit
les gars
juste comme les couples qui s'entendent
bien qui sont heureux puis que tout va
bien jusqu'à la fin
ça fait pas grand chose c'est comme pour
faire un bon show il faut faire un show
que le monde veut l'écouter
tu as besoin d'être seul mais ça il
discutable
c'est comme ils sont compagnie
le bon le bon ami de jeu qui qui
a fait il y avait tout ce qui pouvait
en tout cas je trouvais qu'il était
jeune
c'est quand même pas celui mettons moi
je trouve pour écouter les autres années
mais au final c'est
quand même bon pour comme calmer les
ardeurs puis genre c'est pas lui
pollu la source
c'est tout un écosystème parce que toute
seule le public les commanditeurs les
missions tout ça était relié tout le
monde est en train de dépendance tout le
monde dans le sens qui a été l'émission
ils savent bien aussi que ce que le
public veut fac ils vont essayer de
donner ça parce qu'ils veulent avoir les
meilleures possibles parce qu'on met de
la pression par les commenceurs pour
aller mettre des coups de passer puis
c'est tous ceux c'est comme ça c'est
entre nourrit ça fait une escalade du
truc
avoir des des pubs à livrer puis qu'on
va dire on pense qu'il va avoir autant
d'écoute puis finalement il y a pas tant
d'écoutes
du sujet je pense que oui l'affaire est
ketchup
bon ok là j'ai une liste des questions
mais là je vais je les ai pas mis en or
je vais essayer de choisir une bonne
deuxième question je les ai pas entendu
d'avance j'ai même pas lu d'avance ah
ouais c'est bon
Marie GF que salut
premièrement merci premièrement merci
premièrement c'est pas terminé encore
c'est pas terminé au moment où on se
parle ont encore en train de
parcours le 4e
puis ça ça c'est un projet qui doit être
là
c'est la première fois aux studiosf
qu'on fait une coproduction c'est à dire
que nous on arrive avec une idée de
projet
puis computer dans le fond puis à cette
fois là ça a été à Québec
ordio numérique je suis pas comment
qu'il faut qu'on les appelle il y a
plusieurs niveaux mais que radio puis on
travaille conjointement avec eux pour
faire le truc nous on s'occupe vraiment
de la production dans le fond c'est la
production à proprement parler
on en a parlé déjà sur un clowné par le
passé mais on l'avait comme disait on
l'avait attisé mais là c'est sorti puis
écoute c'est c'est de l'apprentissage
quand même parce que c'est un projet
d'envergure quand même c'est un huit
épisodes d'une demi-heure mais c'est
avec recherche avec scénario avec
enquête de dire puis avec aussi c'est
avec une part des responsabilités aussi
parce que tu diriges avec des vraies
histoires des vrais humains des vrais
toutes les
peut-être qu'elle est ouais peut-être
que
la musique nous appartient
les masters
même si la tune n'appartient pas que
juste comme les revenus de Spotify
pour l'instant
rien de confirmé pour l'instant rien
enfermé on verra rien confirmé mais nous
l'objectif ça fait longtemps c'est au
studio on en avait déjà parlé tu sais on
voulait faire des productions originales
le thé évidemment c'est que ça Ralph il
faut qu'on s'appelle sans filtre qui
sont des productions originales puis
après ça on s'était dit ben là peut-être
qu'on a fait le tour de ce type de
podcast là tu sais de podcast
conversationnel comme nous on fait ici
au sans filtre fait que ça fait
longtemps qu'on se dit qu'on veut faire
ça puis on s'était dit initialement avec
ce projet ça fait longtemps qu'on est
assis quand même le projet avec Victoria
qu'on lobe qu'on le reforme
un peu puis quand le pitch puis
on voulait l'utiliser un peu comme une
carte d'affaires pour essayer de pouvoir
faire et regarder si on est capable de
faire un truc de même puis de pouvoir
proposer d'autres d'autres projets même
parce que j'ai l'impression puis je l'ai
déjà dit dans d'autres podcasts
peut-être mais que
excusez-moi l'avenir du podcast c'est
vraiment ça c'est des podcasts vraiment
l'impression que c'est là que ça s'en va
puis que tu sais c'est déjà là aux
États-Unis toutes les podcasts les plus
écoutées maintenant c'est l'histoire qui
sont racontées c'est des trucs à part
mettons toujours regen encore mais c'est
des trucs comme ça plus construits tu
sais puis j'ai l'impression que c'est là
que ça s'en va puis c'est vraiment le
fun c'est gratifiant à mort ça va faire
le vraiment c'est le projet comme tel tu
l'écoutes ça tu l'écoutes vraiment comme
une série tu sais puis c'est bon c'est
pas il y a pas de c'est ça va plus loin
ça critique plus loin que
que que ça soit plus parler
moins de travail par exemple
de recherche on essaie de comme c'est
amener ça à haut niveau c'est d'avoir
des vrais répercussions
on verra s'il y a d'autres projets qui
se présentent c'est fort possible tout à
fait possible
je pense que vous allez triper
Marco Robin
avez-vous peur le tour du monde qui vous
intéresse ça c'est une bonne question
c'est une question qu'on se pose ouais
en fait la réponse je pense qu'on l'a
déjà
qu'on a fait la fin du sans filtre vous
maintenant tu mettons qu'on est tombé à
deux podcasts par semaine un podcast à
chaque deux semaines tu fais 30 secondes
qu'on a fait ce podcast là
ça fait déjà un petit bout de qu'on est
quand on est éloigné de ça puis c’était
la réflexion qu'on avait eu c'est parce
qu'on s'était nous deux on s'est adressé
la liste des gens qu'on voulait recevoir
puis
soit on les avait déjà reçu soit ils
avaient dit non ou soit ils avaient
gosté
tout le monde sa liste
qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec ça c'était un
peu la remise en question de sans filtre
puis après ça d'arriver avec l'idée de
faire des podcasts vraiment plus sur le
sujet que sur l'invité
devenait vraiment ce qui nous je pense
nous motiver le plus à faire et oui
parce que souvent les podcasts qu'on
sortait on est en sentiment de d'avoir
appris quelque chose
qui se maîtrise un sujet peut-être
intéressant
même si les il y avait moins de monde
essentiellement qui écoutait ses
podcasts là juste par le fait même que
c'est c'est déjà moins populaire c'est
les podcasts desquels je me faisais le
plus parler au quotidien par des gens
parce que tu sais c'est ça et puis ça je
dirais après ça à ce niveau là la liste
est vraiment plus longue
des sujets des idées de sujets des idées
d'inviter pour être des sujets un peu
plus niches ou des sujets d'actualité je
pense que ça c'est
une épuisable maintenant mais aussi
quelque chose qui fait que le sans
filtre au départ mais quand on a
commencé
c'était les débuts
des podcasts au Québec des podcasts de
conversation avec des personnalités
[Musique]
podcast ça fait des podcasts
je pense que
ok ok
il y avait des gens qui venaient louer
l'espace l'atelier pour enregistrer leur
podcast puis en sortant il disait que
le matin je vous écoute j'ai écouté le
podcast avec Sonia Lupien puis l'autre
qui était juste à côté qui est une prof
d'université a dit ouais je le fais
écouter à mes étudiants
c'est encore lui à ce jour que le plus
d'écoute en audio puis qui continue à
avoir des écoutes à chaque semaine genre
grandement d'écoute à chaque semaine fou
ça passe cette dame là est incroyable
premièrement tu sais c'est vraiment
grâce à elle mais le sujet mais c'est
quand même fascinant
aussi sur
ce collectivement comment
ça les intéresse autant puis qu'il
retourne qu'il l'écoute qu'ils font
l'écoutait du monde c'est que on est
vraiment
à l'époque où est-ce que tout le monde
dit avec ses problématiques-là
peut-être qu'on peut faire une
parenthèse sur ce mais encore à ce jour
la faire du du podcast de
Sonia Lupien qui me reste le plus dans
tête c'est
l'énergie mobilisée quand elle nous a
parlé d'énergie mobilisée pour ceux qui
ont pas écouté le podcast je vous
encourage grandement à aller l'écouter
je me rappelle plus psychos son numéro
mais elle est mentionne l'énergie
mobilisée puis c'est comme des fois
quand tu passes ta journée puis tu
travailles à l'ordinateur mettons tu
réponds à des mails tu fais peu importe
c'est quoi ton job puis tu arrives chez
vous plutôt comme un espèce de
brain que tu vois plus clair au dessus
depuis capable de penser genre un peu
paralysé par dans un mauvais mot un
mauvais mot aussi exact puis que ça
c'est de l'énergie que ton corps parce
que tu vivais un stress constant pendant
que tu étais au travail pendant que tu
es dans ta vie puis ton corps crée de
l'énergie pour avoir en réponse de
stress comme s'il y avait un éléphant en
pièce
puis que si tu dépenses pas cette
énergie là ou en partie
ton corps est comme ta ta suivre
l'énergie de ton corps fais casque a
recommandé c'est comme va prendre une
marge de 15 minutes dans un salon
pendant 10 minutes toi tu fais des
push-ups alors ça t'arrive ici des fois
tu le fais moi je vois souvent jusqu'au
rire
pendant que tu le fais c'est fou parce
que les cinq premières minutes
mettons-le tu as encore ça plus
tranquillement c'est vraiment genre
l'image est trop clair pour moi c'est
comme vraiment s'il y a un coup de vent
qui passe dans ta tête soudainement
genre là tu revois clair mais oui c'est
fou le ça depuis qu'elle en a parlé là
je sais quand ça m'arrive parce qu'avant
ça m'est arrivé j'étais quand même ce
que je fais le type là tu es comme pas
mal jusqu'à tant que tu te couches tu
dors mal puis maintenant je sais que
c'est ça je fais ok non là ce qui se
passe en ce moment c'est pas que tu es
fatigué ou que tu as fini ta journée
c'est juste que ton corps trop d'énergie
mobilisée dépenses le puis tu peux
continuer après ça
ça répond c'est drop ça répond
exactement à une autre question puis on
peut continuer sur le sujet là mais il y
avait Melian 19 qui demandait le son
apprise au podcast que vous avez mise en
pratique dans vos vies puis pour moi tu
sais mettons je pense qu'un podcast que
le plus d'impact c'est lui le comme tu
dis moi c'est la même chose c'est c'est
des trucs que je vivais mais que mettons
ce bac à slam m'a vraiment fait réaliser
l'effet comme du sport en fait que
que je savais mais que là maintenant
dans notre conscience et comme je le
réalise à quel point c'est fou justement
quand tu vois faire du sport quand tu
bouges mais là je pense que le sport
[Rires]
mais c'est parce qu'on mentionne souvent
le sport mais continue non non c'est
vraiment le soir mais
c'est sûr puis justement d'être capable
de le voir
c'est parce que j'étais stressé toute la
journée ou c'est parce que si ce puis là
pour aller mieux qu'une solution il y a
une solution il faut que je fasse ça
moi mettons
de faire du sport régulièrement puis des
fois des périodes justement que
plus dans le jus moins de temps faire du
sport les périodes les plus stressantes
au final souvent les périodes que je
vais faire le moins de sport parce que
je manque de temps mais c'est les
périodes que c'est le plus nécessaire
maintenant mais si mettons qu'un deux
trois jours qui se passe demain c'est
vraiment dans le jus pas de sport
je suis comme je suis pas la même
personne complètement une autre personne
je suis genre je suis moins présent je
suis moins relax je suis moins agréable
je suis moins tout type puis je m'abonde
à la voie tout de suite là mettons des
fois je vais arriver à maison plus
j'étais encore dans ma tête puis là
normalement puis genre
c'est comme diva courir c'est ça le
besoin d'aller courir genre quand je
reviens de courir un petit peu le temps
alors tu m'aimes plus quand tu reviens
de courir parce que là je reviens plus
je suis extrêmement bien j'ai le goût de
la tu sais j'ai le goût de la coller
j'ai le goût genre comme tu es comme je
suis dans un bon mindset puis c'est le
jour et la nuit
c'est
enseignement là est un live je sais que
on Martel le clown on en parle de sport
mais c'est parce que
j'ai pas de meilleur conseil à donner
non autre que
tu pensais faire du sport
moi j'ai des amis là tu dis justement
comme plein de monde avec l'anxiété avec
le stress chronique et puis
je réponds tout le temps la même affaire
genre essaie d'intégrer le sport dans ta
routine c'est puis genre des fois le
monde te parle de ça puis c'est comme si
il y avait pas de solution mais c'est
comme
il y en a une si tu fais ça
c'est sûr ça va pas c'est ça c'est sûr
que ça va aider ça va pas nécessaire
que c'est sûr que ça va aider mais puis
c'est ce que tu dis mettons de des fois
ça t'arrive ton 3 jours comme à côté
je me permets juste plus que ça m'arrive
ça m'arrive juste plus maintenant puis
des fois c'est vraiment chiant c'est
maintenant des fois j'ai pas j'aurais
envie de rien car
après une grosse journée aller courir
une heure là c'est vraiment chiant et
puis tu peux courir moins qu'une heure
là évidemment tout est lourd tu sentais
les articulations font mal mais ton
petit mais
je le fais maintenant je me je
m'autorise plus à pas le faire parce que
c'est ça que ça me fait
jamais on regrette jamais on regrette
jamais ça c'est clair on regarde jamais
anonyme demande
vos buts pour 2023
[Rires]
nos buts pour demain 23
je le fais ça c'est juste que
je t'ai déjà parlé de mon
le genre de très chaude tous les genres
de ligne mettons en dessous de laquelle
tu acceptes plus fort j'accepte les
affaires cette ligne-là est définie par
plein facteurs mais au final c'est
comment ça me tente de faire quelque
chose
mais c'est sûr il y a plein d'enfants
qui rentrent en ligne de compte mais
à chaque fois que je décide de comme
monter ta ligne ou à monter ma ligne
puis comme le plus fort quelque chose
que ça qui comme devenu en bas de cette
très chaude là il y a quelque chose
d'autre qui arrive
je peux pas dire non
mais c'est malade dans le fond c'est
incroyable mettons depuis qu'on a parlé
de cette méthode depuis un an depuis
[Musique]
mettons dans ma vie
personnelle puis tu as ma carrière
mettons
surtout en tant que musicien
ça a quand même vraiment
changer tout autour
avant la pandémie je connais ma vie avec
ça mais tu faisais
surtout des trucs plus
en guillemets alimentaires c'est des
geeks de musiciens
de guitaristes professionnels la gauche
à droite c'est pour gagner ma vie mais
qui était un bonnassement des choses que
je me voyais petit à faire de la musique
puis que ça allait être sûr et puis je
me disais dans ma vie puis c'est quand
même malade c'est quand même
avec ça après ça la pandémie à être
complètement arrêté à rien faire puis là
aussi aujourd'hui à télécharger de
tourner en Europe avec Ariane avec sur
jouer de la musique qu'on a travaillé
ensemble et puis que certaines tonnes
qu'on a composé ensemble que
puis d'avoir construit ce projet-là
d'aller à Paris puis que le monde chante
les tonnes qui connaissent les tonnes à
Paris puisqu'on va en Suisse qu'on va en
Belgique c'est fou
puisqu'elle mettons pour déjà 2023 des
projets qui sont en ligne c'est de
musique de films de musique de
réalisation d'albums des artistes que
j'estime vraiment
c'est comme
mais ça fait de la place pour des trucs
plus dense à chaque fois
tu prends juste plus
je prends juste différentes choses mais
c'est sûr que ultimement mettons dans la
vie
mon but c'est pas travailler sur Deezer
semaine toute ma vie c'est sûr qu'il va
falloir trouver quelque chose trouver
plus un genre de
méthode de pour y arriver mais
pour travailler beaucoup d'heures
il y avait des questions il y avait deux
questions qui étaient plus dirigées sur
les sujets qu'on parle vraiment en fait
ou c'est mal en parler question pour
deux je le perle 99 je le perle qui
qui ont qui revient souvent je pense
même que c'est lui qui a donné l'idée du
boudoir comme nom de
l'atelier un des deux parce qu'il savait
que c'était qu'on était en mode Québec
j'ai une pelle c'est un vrai 99 merci
d'être là question pour dôme pour nous
de tes projets musicaux présents et à
venir avec fierté la question c'est pas
nous en pauvre juste par nous dire avec
fierté mais là j'ai un peu d'en parler
avec fierté
en ce moment avec Ariane avec
les mini projets qui s'en viennent
il y a un truc dernière fois qu'on a
fait un kyanais je m'étais comique à
quelque chose que j'ai jamais fait
finalement de quoi je parle j'avais dit
puis ça c'est la question aussi de Jimmy
chameau qui est un podcast de musique ça
s'en vient puis j'ai jamais fait non bon
parce que justement
ça c'est ça c'est un lien que tu achètes
dans le corps
qui était comme dans mon trouble 3
priorité de trucs que je veux vraiment
faire
avec le temps puis pensant
peut-être que je dois le faire mais là
en ce moment c'est plus dans mon taux de
propriété puis un nouveau projet dans
mon top 3
j'en parle encore une fois même je sais
pas si je te crois quand tu fais ça
écoute
on verra
un album personnel j'ai commencé à
écrire des tonnes j'ai commencé à créer
des tonnes j'ai commencé à travailler
seul j'ai fait des petits démos de Toon
je suis quand même content
genre
Damien Rice style autant qu'on peut soit
interprète
mais oui là c'est des chansons que c'est
moi j'avais écrit le texte de ma vie tu
sais tout le temps était un peu la truc
qui me paralysait parce que
la musique ça va je fais de la musique
depuis toujours mais tu sais
composer de la musique de quelque chose
complètement
[Musique]
le truc que je me sentais imposteur que
je me sentais ben là j'ai pas étudier
là-dedans j'ai pas appris formellement
comment faire ça j'ai pas une ananas
puis je m'étais pas attardé non plus
tant que ça parce que quand j'écoute de
la musique souvent les paroles pour moi
c'est comme secondaire secondaire du
coup du moins à première écoute c'est
pas de la dessus que je focus
c'est
le jour de ma fête
maisons
je pense qu'il faut que ça faisait
une coupe de tonne puis je vais dans
l'enregistrer le rapidement
qui comme on peut mon projet personnel
excitant que que
le nom Dominique plante ça va être avec
quoi non
je pense pas que ça soit Dominique
plainte là
de ramener à toi je pense que oui je
pense ça va être comme si mettons les
louanges ouais louange c'est un 12 c'est
pas belle louange c'est Vincent Robert
ça serait peut-être un jour de nom de
même c'est un genre de nom d'artistes
beaucoup de musiciens professionnels qui
qui tuait pour avoir le
[Rires]
mais je me pose de plus en plus de
questions est-ce que tu es en ligne avec
moi
avec vraiment qui je suis qu'est-ce que
j'aime pitié je
laisse de plus en plus mon
mon identité pendant mon individualité
mettons guidé mais décisions plus que
genre juste être comme le gars qui comme
caméléon puis qui peut faire un peu
doute puis qui veut dire oui à toute et
qui va se fondre dans n'importe quel
contexte
j'essaie de comme trouver moi c'est quoi
ma couleur c'est quoi qui je suis
mettons
prétentieux mais en tant qu'artiste
trouver des trucs qui sont alignés avec
ceux puis laisser ceux qui dit mes choix
là
essayez de comme dans n'importe quel
contexte de ma vie mettons ce musical
peu importe
le sentiment que
je peux être 100% moi-même
c'était quoi la question il y a eu plein
de questions mais la question originale
2023 j'étais écouté à fait que j'ai pas
pensé à ma réponse seulement question il
y a plein d'affaires rien à faire en
2023 ça coïncide
avec la fin de mes remboursements de
prêt étudiant ok la fin de mon paiement
de moto mon paiement de voiture toute
fin toute finir en 2023
en fait c'est juste que j'aimerais ça
comme pour la première fois de ma vie
puis là ça va paraître super
monétaire mon objectif le titre mais
c'est vraiment pas ça l'idée c'est pas
ça du tout mais c'est que j'aimerais ça
arriver comme à un moment en 2023 je
sais pas quand plutôt que tard
optimalement mais avant un moment où
est-ce que j'ai comme plus de dettes
puis ça stresse là
surtout
mais dans le sens plus de remboursement
puis de voir d'argent à personne parce
que même si j'avais accumulé de l'argent
maintenant je pourrais pas rembourser
mes dettes d'études qui sont comme un
taux fixe depuis que je suis sorti de
l'université que je rembourse
tranquillement mais là ça va finir tu
sais que j'aimerais ça comme clair et
toutes les cartes de crédit clair et mes
dettes étudiante mais prêt pour de shop
puis de voir d'argent à personne ce sera
la première fois depuis que je suis un
adulte que j'ai pas ça
je sais pas si tu
je lis plus vraiment les commentaires
nulle en fait sur mes affaires puis mais
je me rappelle que la dernière fois
qu'on avait fait un kiwi on avait
demandé au monde dit ce que vous pensez
c'est
des commentaires
qui disait parce que au début je
mentionne on parle qu'on veut voter
maintenant plus je mentionne que je suis
sûr de voter pour qest puis une fille
d'un commentaire qui dit genre on sait
bien maintenant vous êtes des hommes
d'affaires à succès
vous voulez changer votre vote d'épaule
c'est quand même je te garantis que tu
veux pas changer de compte de banque
avec le mien en ce moment je te jure
c'est quand même là ce serait parce que
toute l'argent que j'ai jamais accumulé
je l'ai mis dans des business avec j'ai
jamais pu rembourser rien jamais pu
avoir un backup pour comme
me baquer sauf que là j'ai arrêté de
faire ces investissements là évidemment
j'ai eu
d'autres
courants de la dernière année que
j'avais pas prévu mais que là c'est
quand même là je vois pas investir mes
affaires je reprends tranquillement
commencer à peut-être hacker pour
pouvoir au moins pu avoir ça
tu penses des fois le l'argent tu y
penses des fois c'est un IP pensé c'est
vraiment pas mal c'est l'argent
c'est l'argent fait pas le bonheur mais
pas le malheur non plus
non mais dans le sens que c'est
l'argent l'argent pour l'argent je veux
dire c'est rien mais l'argent
c'est synonyme de temps c'est synonyme
de liberté
mettons que toi ce qui est important
pour toi dans vie
c'est de passer du temps plus possible
de temps avec
ta famille donc c'est ce toi dans la vie
monétairement c'est pas beaucoup
d'argent tu travailles mettons
je peux le dire
[Musique]
une famille à nourrir
tome -
le temps de faire ce que tu fais
vraiment faire le plus dans la vie
d'un côté musique le titre du monde qui
pourrait mettons charger vraiment plus
cher qu'est-ce qui change mais ton pour
leur service puis là je leur dis crime
important pour moi mais c'est comme
Spock
pour toi puis le fait de charger plus
cher votre permet d'avoir de pouvoir
plus dédié ta vie à ce qu'il est à ce
qui veut pas dire que justement si
mettons ton bus et travailler moins se
charge deux fois plus cher ben tu peux
travailler tu peux faire le même salaire
travailler deux fois moins puis faire
tous les affaires que tu veux faire
comme moi c'est ça c'est quand même
important d'y penser puis trouver des
manières de rendre ça
comme
de trouver des manières justement de
pouvoir
atteindre tes objectifs puis faire
vraiment ce que tu veux faire
grâce à l'argent je vais prendre ça
pour dire que c'est
parmi mes objectifs
plus largement peut-être thé au studio
aussi on a mis en place on a une
nouvelle employé maintenant qui va moi
me libérer
assez drastiquement puis ça c'est un
objectif aussi tu sais parce que le
studio m'a demandé avec raison parce
qu'il y a plein de projets vraiment le
fun là mais me demandait vraiment du
temps
démesuré versus mettons les tâches dans
lesquelles je pourrais être plus
efficace ou meilleur là je faisais pas
mal la job que
dans lesquels je suis pas spécialiser
spécialiser et puis beaucoup de gestion
ça ça m'intéressait moins
comme délégué plus pour le studio puis
de pouvoir c'est mieux gérer mon temps
puis
de pouvoir penser peut-être justement
c'est pour relier à la question de si on
a d'autres projets comme cela de
Victoria peut-être prendre ce temps-là
puis le mettre dans quelque chose comme
ça plus que dans de la gestion pour
faire de quoi être plus créatif de plus
fun c'est là moi je travaille quand même
en proximité avec Véronique qui
l'Autriche de du balado post mortem puis
ça c'est comme intellectuellement
vraiment fun tu sais mais oui vraiment
créatif puis de quoi qui est plus
gratifiant que de répondre à des emails
c'est super pour faire ça même que
essentiellement représente probablement
mieux et prendre la plus
chaleureuse et accueillante pour les
clients que moi je pourrais que genre
c'est comme c'est un bon trader puis ça
je pense que de stabiliser cette
situation là
à l'envers 2023 je pense c'est bon mon
objectif
on a quand même réussi c'est quand même
été une grosse année pour left et puis
on a réussi à redresser le bateau puis
comme c'est quand même
je pense qu'on peut se féliciter un bon
travail
et sinon
aujourd'hui c'est la fin de mon premier
Black Friday où est-ce que je vends des
produits ouais ouais c'est le studio il
y a pas de Black Friday au studio dans
les dans les entreprises de service il y
en a essentiellement très peu mais c'est
la première fois que je vendais quelque
chose par un black friday puis ça a été
la folie
Québec parce que demain je vais
littéralement passer toute la journée à
faire ça à faire des commandes toute la
journée au complet
puis non ça a été ça a été bon sauf que
là ça tourne ça va être ça va
de continuer à
stabiliser tout le truc puis m'assurer
de de bien faire les prochains steps
mieux faire la gestion des menteurs pour
la deuxième année dans le fond ça fait
même pas un an comment changer
qu'on allait passer si on vendait notre
première commande en un an on allait
être content puis on est rendu à moitié
de la troisième
ça a été ça de voir
ce concrétise puis voir mettons une
deuxième saison parce que les saisons
commencent mettons le monde commence à
s'entraîner en fin février début mars
pour les la saison estivale puis
effectivement on est en plein dans sa
saison morte puis ça roule quand même
encore fait que j'ai hâte de voir si
comme ça ça va se traduire vers une
deuxième saison vraiment
hôte mais c'est le fun aussi c'est ça me
permet de m'entraîner
mais oui quand même dans ma vie
[Musique]
de course où est-ce que j'ai vu
pour les gens qui veulent checker le
club Epica sur ce travail c'est genre ça
fait deux activités qu'on organise on
veut juste laisser la course mais ça va
être du vélo de natation de la farine
puis on va faire des challenges aussi
autant virtuel que en présentiel fait
que vous pouvez vous inscrire sur le
club
upicka sur Strava puis vous allez
pouvoir suivre tout ça ouais sinon
performer comme jamais exact
à parler après deux semaines c'est la
preuve que on vieillit